-Yet another MAGA Republican
handpicked by Donald Trump
has lost a key race
in a battleground state,
this time in Georgia,
where Democratic incumbent
Raphael Warnock
won the Senate runoff
last night,
giving Democrats
full control of the chamber
without needing a tiebreaker,
and defying the odds
in a year Republicans thought
would be a red wave.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
One way you know
that Herschel Walker
was deeply unqualified to serve
in the United States Senate
was that even Republicans
would rarely let him go
on Fox News by himself.
Instead, he was almost always
accompanied by a chaperone,
South Carolina Senator
Lindsey Graham,
who seemed to do
most of the talking.
-This is the year
of the Georgia Bulldog,
and there is no bigger Georgia
Bulldog than Herschel Walker.
I want every liberal to be
miserable come election night.
TeamHerschel.com.
So, TeamHerschel.com,
if you want to close.
-Yeah, go to TeamHerschel.com
and --
-But I want to say one thing.
This man will change
the Republican Party.
You're gonna win this race.
TeamHerschel.com.
Go light up the internet.
-Senator Graham, you --
-If you will give
to TeamHerschel.com
right now tonight,
I will do 50 push-ups
on your show.
but you got to give now.
-Man, I understand why they let
Lindsey Graham do the talking,
but they didn't even trust
Herschel with the push-ups?
[ Laughter ]
That's really a testament to how
little faith they had in him.
[As Graham] I'm not saying
Herschel's dumb,
but the last time I asked him
to give me 50 push-ups,
he robbed the bra store.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[Normal voice] But I have to
say, when I heard that,
I almost gave money
to Herschel Walker
because I would love
to see Lindsey Graham
attempt 50 push-ups.
[As Graham] Oh, I can do --
I can do 50 push-ups.
My meemaw made me do that
as a punishment
whenever I forgot to clean
her hemorrhoid donut.
You can put it in the dishwasher
yourself, Meemaw!
I ain't cleanin' it anymore!
Fine!
[ Laughter ]
One...
[Normal voice] By the way,
I'm not saying
I could bang out 50, either.
Here's how I do 50 push-ups.
I do a set of 20, then 15,
ten, one, one, one,
one, one,
hospital.
Shockingly, the strategy
of doing exercise stunts
for money did not work.
Warnock beat Walker handily
last night in a state
where the Republican governor
won by eight points.
And one reason for that
is people are just tired
of Trump's handpicked clown car
of bozos and doofuses.
For example,
we told you a few weeks ago
about a very bizarre,
lengthy rant
Walker went on
at a campaign stop
about vampires and werewolves.
The story was so long
and detailed,
it would take us
the rest of this segment
to show you the whole thing,
but here's how it started.
-You ever watch a stupid movie
late at night
hoping it gonna get better,
it don't get better,
but you keep watching it anyway?
'Cause the other night --
the other night
I was watching this movie,
I was watching this movie
called "Fright Night,"
"Freak Night" --
some type of night.
But it was about vampires.
I don't know if you know --
vampires some cool people,
are they not?
But I'mma tell you something
that I found out.
A werewolf can kill a vampire.
Did you know that?
I never knew that.
So I don't want to be
a vampire anymore.
I want to be a werewolf.
-Herschel Walker wanted to be
a werewolf, but in reality,
he was really more of
a who-what-when-why-where-wolf.
[ Laughter ]
In that every time that
he opened his mouth, you said,
"What? When? Who? Why? Where?"
There was at least one
small victory
for Walker last night, though.
They asked the same question
in the exit polls,
and it turns out that vampires
are, in fact, cool people.
[ Laughter ]
Now, the reason
why we showed you that
is it actually played
a pretty big role
at the end of the runoff
when President Obama
went to Georgia
to campaign for Warnock
and mocked Walker
for the vampire story.
In fact, Obama couldn't even
start talking about it
without laughing.
-Since the last time
I was here --
[ Laughing ]
Since the last time I was here,
Mr. Walker
has been talking about issues
that are of great importance
to the people of Georgia,
like whether it's better
to be a vampire or a werewolf.
[ Laughter ]
This is a debate that I must
confess I once had myself.
[ Laughter ]
When I was seven.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Then I grew up.
[ Crowd cheers ]
In case you're wondering,
by the way,
Mr. Walker decided
he wanted to be a werewolf.
Which is great.
As far as I'm concerned,
he can be anything
he wants to be,
except for
a United States senator.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And I do...
I will say,
I do wish I could have seen
seven-year-old Obama debating
whether he wanted to be
a werewolf or a vampire.
[As Obama] Uh, now,
on the one hand,
vampires, they're immortal.
On the other hand,
werewolves can dunk.
[ Laughter ]
[Normal voice]
Also, I want to say,
it is not fair
that in addition to being
one of the most skilled
politicians
and greatest orators
in American history,
Obama also has legit
comedy chops.
Like, it doesn't work
the other way.
None of my comedy friends
could ever be president.
Because first of all,
you got to get up before 11:00.
I'm pretty sure
they drug test you.
If a White House aide ever
has to utter the words,
"President Samberg,
the nukes are headed our way,"
we're [bleep]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Mostly because --
Mostly because if that happened,
he would not stop doing
his Nicolas Cage impression.
"Sir, we need to call
the president of Russia
immediately."
"Or I could break
into the Kremlin."
"We do not have time
for your impressions, sir.
They have already fired
their nukes."
"I just hope
they don't aim one
at my doink!"
[ Explosion ]
Walker was so deeply unqualified
that much of the time it seemed
like he didn't even know
what was going on.
Even Walker's fellow Republicans
warned months ago
that he could lose.
The only reason
he was even a candidate
for Senate in the first place
was that he was once
on Donald Trump's game show.
Donald Trump fired him
from "The Celebrity Apprentice,"
but thought he might do better
in the United States Senate.
[As Trump] Herschel,
I don't know if you're ready
to sell corndogs
in Times Square.
So let's put you in charge
of the US military first.
[ Laughter ]
Besides, if you wanted to
nominate a game show contestant,
you could do much better.
Just pick literally anyone who's
ever been on "Family Feud."
Well, anyone but this woman.
-Name something that might be
all over a woman.
Ale?
-I don't know how to say
this elegantly, but [bleep]
[ Audience ohhs ]
-Good answer! Good answer!
-We didn't bleep that.
They did.
What did she say?!
[ Laughter ]
What could the answer
have possibly been?
Look what this woman did
to poor Steve Harvey.
Do you know how filthy
your answer has to be
to completely silence
Steve Harvey?!
I've never seen
so much existential dread
in one man's eyes.
You know what
the worst part was?
Number one answer.
[ Laughter and applause ]
The point is, Walker is yet
another Trump-picked candidate
who cost Republicans a seat
that they had
very much hoped to win.
Republicans were completely
on board
and did everything they could
to help Walker win,
despite the fact that he was
very obviously unqualified.
But now,
even many of Trump's former
allies are turning on him.
Yesterday,
before the results even came in,
Fox Business host Stuart Varney
laid into Trump
for backing so many
losing candidates.
-There's a lot at stake here.
It's more than just the balance
of power in the Senate.
It's about the state
of the Republican Party
and Trump's role in it.
He seems to be losing what used
to be his iron grip on the GOP.
He still has a hard core
of supporters
who will follow him regardless.
But many of the 74 million
people who voted for him in 2020
have been turned off.
-It's such an indictment
of the GOP
that Trump ever had an iron grip
on them to begin with.
It's hard to imagine him
having an iron grip at all.
I imagine shaking Trump's hand
feels a lot like
holding a wet baby bird.
Say what you will
about the Democrats,
I've never heard them refer
to any president,
no matter how popular, as having
an iron grip on the party.
No one talks like that
unless they're in
"House of the Dragon."
Although I do think
Trump could recapture
some of that energy he once had
if he just started
showing up to rallies
wearing that golden mask
Viserys wears.
[As Trump] Rhaenyra --
We love Rhaenyra,
don't we, folks?
And don't forget about
her dragon Syrax.
Syrax -- I met him once.
Big dragon, tough dragon.
He came up to me --
He came up to me,
tears pouring down his face
and then sizzling
in his fiery maw.
And he clutched my entire body
in his giant talons
and then he said to me,
he said, "Mr. Trump, sir? Roar!"
And he breathed fire
all over me.
But my skin is so thick
and resistant...
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter continues ]
...all it did was make me
look like this.
So, there you go.
[Normal voice] And Varney --
Varney wasn't the only one
throwing shade at Trump
after Warnock
was declared the winner.
Fox host Laura Ingraham
and former Trump White House
aide Kellyanne Conway
complained that,
for some reason,
Republicans weren't as good
at using mail-in voting
as Democrats.
-We need to not just compete
for votes, for ballots.
We need to compete for ballots.
If we don't bank ballots early,
we're going to keep losing.
-But we didn't.
-But we didn't do it in 2020
'cause everyone said don't vote
early 'cause that's corrupt.
-Not everyone.
-Well, a lot of people did.
The very top of
the Republican Party.
You didn't.
-Yes, big-name people did.
-Oh, did a lot of people
at the very top
of the Republican Party
say mail-in voting was corrupt?
Huh! I wonder who
those people were.
Even when they're obviously
talking about Trump,
they can't bring themselves
to say his name.
From now on,
whenever someone says
Trump's name on Fox News,
it's gonna sound like this.
[Bleep]
It's so amazing
to watch these people
suddenly start complaining about
the consequences
of their own actions.
You were Trump's
fiercest supporters
when he was claiming
mail-in voting led to fraud,
and now you're whining that
Republicans don't vote by mail.
Sorry, but you can't complain
about a neck bite
after you open the door
and invite in a...
-Vampire.
-The best part...
[ Laughter ]
The best part, though,
was watching them melt down
as the results came in
and desperately search
for anyone
other than Trump to blame.
-This is what we expected,
and now look.
The Senate Democrats,
I would argue,
did a much better job
and they got the early vote out.
We felt this coming.
To me, it never felt like
the Senate Republicans
wanted this guy in office.
He was a Trump pick.
They didn't like that.
There wasn't the intensity
on the part of the Republicans
as there was on the part
of the Democrats.
I felt it. You felt it.
But we don't change anything.
We have the same people
in place in leadership.
Same people in place,
apparently, at the RNC.
That's not -- perhaps
that's not changing.
We just keep doing the same
thing over and over again.
I'm pissed tonight, frankly.
-Alright, first of all,
Laura Ingraham has the energy
of a country club patron
who's been made aware
they've changed chefs.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"They fired Mario?
They fired my Mario?
But he used to make the most
delightful chèvre brioche.
I'm pissed."
Second, you're mad
that Senate Republicans
didn't want Walker to join them?
You think they wanted to spend
all their downtime between votes
talking about whether vampires
are cooler than werewolves?
You think that's
Mitch McConnell's idea
of a good time?
Besides, you know
he's gonna pick vampires.
He'd never side against
one of his own.
I do enjoy imagining
that conversation, though.
[As McConnell]
Uh, Herschel, just remember,
we, uh, need you to vote,
uh, no on the bill.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, uh, Herschel,
we've been over this.
Uh, vampires are cooler
than werewolves.
[ Laughter ]
Uh-huh. Yeah, yeah. Mm.
No, no, I know a werewolf
can kill a vampire, Herschel.
Yeah, yeah. But, uh...
But a vampire, Herschel...
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, but a vampire
can turn into a bat.
[ Laughter ]
He dropped the phone.
[ Laughs ]
[Normal voice]
Republicans are finally facing
the political consequences
of their actions.
Their unflinching loyalty
to Donald Trump
is now destroying their party,
and Walker is just
the latest example.
He was deeply unqualified
to be a senator.
On top of that, I'm not even
sure he wanted to be one.
If only Republicans
had asked him
what he actually wanted to be,
he could have told them...
-I want to be a werewolf.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]